so uh the matrix came out today and i
watched it everybody need to get another
drink and it was conservative propaganda
i was triggered i was i was where did
you did you go to a theater no i just
watched it on hbo max oh my gosh it was
conservative propaganda i was triggered
what and i was screaming but i was at it
i was at an impasse i didn't know who to
complain to to get it banned
so um no but in all seriousness i'm only
half kidding i don't want to spoil the
movie for people want to see it but
a large component of the film i believe
maybe it was unintentional but it kind
of
casts the left as like
bad how
i'd have to spoil the film to explain oh
man yep how are we going to review this
it an element of the film
expresses leftist ideas from the
villain's perspective
and in the end and the end of the film
they outright tell regular people
to like take the red pill what like no
joke
and a core element of the film is the
power of a traditional family
beautiful not kidding that's enough
absolutely
and and did anything i'm going to say
one one thing yeah
that will spoil that may spoil some of
the film spoiler alert so you have been
warned
you have been warned i'm saying it one
more time i am going to say an element
of the film which i believe will spoil a
part of the film i'm not gonna give you
a plot point i'm not gonna explain what
neo does or why he's doing what he does
but i will just say this okay now that
you've been warned sufficiently
a core element of the film is that
they're they're
in order in order for humanity to exist
there needs to be a matriarch and a
patriarch there needs to be a man and
woman working together wait i thought
men and women were exactly the same dude
i thought that actually you could change
from being a man into a woman isn't that
isn't that what the matrix was really
about basically
you really think that that was what it
was about originally come on
i mean like the the guys that character
switch in the film yeah was actually in
the film right you know the character
switch was right sure trans person i
understand that but
the the creators they're trans
yes yes uh and but wasn't it sort of
backward mapped onto the matrix later
that the the real intent behind the
movie was to like extol trans virtues i
wouldn't know uh so here's what they say
about that in the uh the first word that
i think appears in the film is trans it
says trans system operator or something
like that
yeah and then there's um it says system
failure and you go between m and f the
film zooms in between mf do you think
there's continuity from the very first
one to this one all out planned like for
example lost absolutely remember the
series
oh
just wonder if they planned it all out
from the beginning the estrogen pills in
the 90s were red pills
and so apparently they were saying take
the red pill was take the estrogen pill
take the estrogen pill you hear that
manosphere you hear that manosphere
y'all been y'all been eating estrogen
pills this entire time
holy cow i knew there was something up
with those guys hilarious so this is
from uh a year ago bread pill died
it says look
at the newsweek the matrix creator
explains what the red pill really is and
men's rights activists aren't going to
be happy
and they they go on to explain there's a
picture of it i think somewhere okay
there's not they're talking about in the
uh uh in the 90s
the the the pill they would take to
transition was a red pill let me see if
i can find that
absolutely hilarious really funny sweet
justice yeah
the uh premarin
oh yeah
is that yeah estrogen it's red pills
imagine if you built your whole brand
about brown being red pilled and it
turns out that it actually meant eating
estrogen wow
no wonder you're a bee now i don't know
if like so some of these things can just
be coincidences
and they and they did they they you know
they back
attached it or whatever
but uh that's what they say i'll tell
you this um
is the zoom in between the m and the f
thing is that is that real it's real
yeah and that that says that's a system
annuity system failure and there's an m
at the end of system and an f and you
and it zooms in past them and the first
word in the film it says trans system
operator or something like that that
could i i honestly when i saw that i was
like what does that mean trans system
operator like what is it i think it's
trance tomorrow i'm not entirely sure
but we watched it again like a couple
weeks ago we watched all three matrix
movies because they're like the new
movies coming out we watch it they're
good the first one's real good the
characters switch
in the first matrix you know the
character switch
is what was supposed to be a person who
goes in the matrix and their residual
self-image was female and then in the
real world they were male or something
and according to the story the studio
thought it was too you know weird for
regular people they wouldn't they
wouldn't like it
i actually think that's a that's a good
idea for a film like if if the idea of
the matrix is you have an identity and
when you go in you become an identity
the only issue is i think people should
turn into giraffes too you know what i
mean right like furries would turn into
bugs bunny and stuff like that but but
that's an interesting concept for a
matrix because we're going to see that
with the metaverse but i'll say this
you've already seen it in fortnight
there's oh yeah there's little boys
acting as
with female characters and nobody
actually lives in every game though i
know but nobody's like nobody even
blinks tonight of that so why in the
metaverse would it be any different why
why would you blink an eye here's the
thing about the matrix resurrections i
don't think it has anything to do with
the matrix at all
like the themes of the original matrix
do not translate into this movie i'm
like it's an entirely different movie
they just call it matrix i think oh i
see yeah i mean
there's there's uh i'll say a few things
the film is
uh hates itself
not exaggerating
they self-reference themselves how much
they hate making this what the heck no
joke like in the movie they basically
say this is garbage we don't want to do
it we don't want to make this are they
contractually obligated
um
i'm gonna i'm gonna go further into
spoilers now for some of you guys so now
i'll get into some direct a direct
spoiler uh it's not a plot point it's
just uh it's part of the early part it's
part of the early movie
i think the first half an hour of the
movie was intended to insult and deride
warner brothers
and then the movie starts gotcha so uh
i'll explain
in the film spoiler warning again
because i really really wanna because
i'm gonna actually give a heart spoiler
uh neo is a game developer
he made a game called the matrix
and he's sitting down with his business
partner and his business partner goes
our parent company warner brothers has
insisted we do a sequel oh my god none
of us want to do it but they said if we
don't do it they'll do it without us oh
man so they were basically looking into
the camera yeah saying it outright
and so the in the movie it's that they
made a video game called the matrix the
warner brothers wants a new matrix game
and they don't want to make it but they
have no choice because either they do it
or it gets remade like trash
so they said fine we'll be involved
and that's the stu i'm watching them
like this is so dumb
the first half an hour is literally them
being like they made us do it we don't
like it don't be mad at us that's it's
kind of seinfeld there is literally a
scripted line that says our parent
company warner brothers expects a sequel
that's literally in the film gotcha and
then there's it's in the trailer
actually not that part but it's where
the guy goes to be going back to where
it all began back to the matrix you've
seen that in the trailer yeah that's
when he's like they're making us redo
this and we don't want to
but the film uh i gotta say like
the left will probably never admit it
but i don't know how else you explain it
that the movie is literally now that
we're in spoiler mode
it's literally uh they're like
neo and trinity as a man and a woman and
the yearning they have for each other is
what stabilizes the matrix and without
them as the patriarch in the matriarch
the new matrix will collapse
that's the plot
get out there and get married guys yeah
yeah yeah sir and guess what happens at
the end because i'm going to give you
the big spoiler oh boy here we go
so neo isn't just the one
trinity also is the one is the two of
them together
so in the original film
neo is the the the patriarch who fights
and saves everybody and and trinity is
just the damsel in distress
in this one
they both have superpowers
i i was shocked by this the villain at
the end says to them
we we will never give up because people
don't want to be free they don't want
the truth they don't want to be
empowered they want to embrace their
feelings over facts
and then neo and trinity are like we're
going to change this world we're not
here to negotiate and i was just like
what
like it doesn't sound like leftist it
sounds like they're conservatives right
uh fostering a human connection the
difference between men and women the
fact that they need to come together
they make fun of binary over and over
and over again likely but so but but
like
it's it's it's weird because
they don't they they they make fun of
like the leftist concept of it
i i it's it's it like they acknowledge
it it's a real thing i'm gonna have to
here's what i said i showed my kids this
movie they did not understand the first
one but hold on hold on here's what i
think
lena witchowski
trans woman made this film yeah but
older trans women
younger younger trans people are the
gender non-binary people what do you
mean like camille poglia style trans
yeah right like she's a trans woman
she's trans but she's a lesbian no she
said specifically i am trans camille
paglia yes for sure fat 100
100 but she's the most based
philosopher of all time love her to
death she's great yeah
she's trans so you look at like um
contra points i think talked i think
talked about this before that older
trans people believe men and women are
the binary and that that's why they're
trans that's why they transition but
younger trans people say it's there's a
million identities you can be whatever
from whatever part of the spectrum
i wonder if
that's really you know like lena
wachowski is like an old school trans
yeah who's like there is a binary and
and they acknowledge that and that's
important to them trans-exclusive
radical trans
trans exclusionary radical trans women i
love it thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you